it's very bad in music or I was not
so he had money
a nice ranch
Burrito
you more
and it did not break
he delivered everything to the music and the stereo
musical of colombia and composed songs
as the totuma as evil spirit
as flares as from the north by the
south and those songs were after
performed by very famous artists
that brought the songs to fame and
they became ambassadors
of Colombia in the world and
they were never given credit because nobody
I knew who had made them one day
he faced during his career a
completely racist music industry
that closed the doors to
music from the coast but they did it
The whites
to turn off
he spoke
I do not dream about that makes me cry
also when I'm already singing and
I lie down hard because I do not
to old age
fasting and praying
tell me you go